[Music]
on this monday night
the man now tasked with taking down
justin trudeau
canada's conservative party gets a
re-tooling
with a new leader you're going to be
seeing and hearing a lot from me
the challenges aaron o'toole now faces
the u.s approves a coven 19 treatment
we've been tracking this
why scientists have concerns as fresh
questions are raised about
how long immunity lasts fire and fury in
wisconsin
the latest case of a white police
officer shooting
a black man and scoring the ultimate
goal
the triumphs and tribulations for a
young canadian
soccer star
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin tonight with a
huge come-from-behind win that ends an
unprecedented race for the conservative
party of canada
aaron o'toole won the party's top job in
convincing fashion
early this morning after a major
technical glitch delayed results
for hours my fellow canadians my name is
aaron o'toole
i believe in this country and i'm
running to serve you
as prime minister it was a crushing
defeat for conservative party co-founder
peter mckay who was considered the
front-runner
o'toole defeated mckay on the third
ballot by a margin of 57 percent
to 43 percent o'toole is promising to
unite the party and vows the
conservatives will be ready to win the
next federal election
but there's a lot of work to do our
chief political correspondent david
aiken has our top story tonight
all right
it was just after 1am ottawa time when
ontario mp
aaron o'toole celebrated his moment of
triumph
to the millions of canadians that are
still up
that i'm meeting tonight for the first
time
good morning i'm aaron o'toole
early morning finish was the result of
some malfunctioning machines that helped
process
175 000 ballots that's an all-time
record for any leadership race
peter mckay had been the presumptive
favorite but o'toole ran an aggressive
campaign from the right
that was an approach that won over
social conservatives
who helped power political newcomer
leslie lewis to a strong
third place finish lewis was just the
second black woman to ever seek the
leadership
of a major canadian federal party and
she's now seen as a rock star in the
conservative party
who is being encouraged to run in the
next general election
when she dropped off the ballot on
sunday
thousands of her supporters swung to
o'toole and that put him over the top
today you have given me a clear mission
to unite
our party to champion our conservative
principles
now o'toole must introduce himself to
canadian voters
you're going to be seeing and hearing a
lot from me in the coming
weeks and months but i want you to know
from the start
that i'm here to fight for you and your
family
o'toole is 47 that's a year younger than
justin trudeau
o'toole spent 12 years in the air force
as a navigator on
sea king helicopters after the air force
o'toole worked as a corporate lawyer
before becoming an mp in 2012
for the riding of durham east of toronto
he took his
first run at the leadership in 2017 but
lost to andrew scheer
now o'toole believes he can do what she
or could not
beat trudeau the world still needs more
canada
it just needs less justin trudeau but
o'toole knows he must do more than just
attack trudeau and
he has promised to put forward a
positive vision
that he thinks is going to attract
liberal and ndp voters
disillusioned with their own parties
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
reaction to o'toole's win is pouring in
but not all of it is positive
the liberals were quick to take aim at
his list of priorities
including the environment i've also
heard that the first thing that aaron
o'toole wants to do is eliminate the
price on pollution i don't think
pollution should be free i think that'd
be a regressive
move i think canadians recognize that
paying for the pollution that comes out
of our tail types and
in other forms of pollution is is just
and the ndp raised concerns about
potential cuts that could come with
o'toole
at the helm this is someone who's been
endorsed by jason
kenney and we've seen certainly in
alberta we've seen
what that type of conservatism does it's
it's cuts to health care it's hot cuts
to child care
cuts to education let's bring in our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stevenson
who spent
hours watching this race last night
mercedes what is the first thing
erin o'toole has to do now that he's the
opposition leader
well robin the first thing he has to do
is get ready for an election because one
could happen
as soon as this fall on september 23rd
justin trudeau and his government will
deliver the throne speech
and there could be a confidence vote
that could bring down the government at
any point
after that that means aaron o'toole has
to have his power players
in position in his inner circle and an
election platform
ready to go even though we're not
expecting the government to fall
necessarily
he has to assume that it could and be
prepared for that he also needs to
introduce himself to canadians
because a lot of people don't know who
aaron o'toole is
that was a big problem for andrew scheer
and a mistake the party can't afford to
make
again he also has to work on getting
party unity together
that should be fairly easy for him he's
pretty well liked but he's got to get
everybody under that big blue tent
in his inner circle okay it's one thing
to win the leadership but now he has to
win over canadians what kind of strategy
will that involve
so he has to move away from the right
side of the spectrum that he's been on
he played himself as a true blue
conservative
in the leadership race to try to get
lots of votes but when he runs in the
general election he's got to be more
centrist
he has to tell canadians what he stands
for not what he doesn't stand for
and they have to have a solid pandemic
response that will tell canadians what
they'll
offer them and especially has to be able
to appeal
to suburban women voters in the 905 in
quebec who could determine the next
election
the liberals are obviously taking note
of this what will justin trudeau and his
team do
with the latest development in the
conservative leadership
well they will exploit that hard right
angle of the campaign
that that aaron o'toole ran on they'll
try to characterize him as a social
conservative
and they will try to say he's basically
andrew scheer or stephen harper light
and define him so for the o'toole people
the issue here is to make sure he's not
defined by justin trudeau but by aaron
o'toole
mercedes-stevenson in ottawa thanks for
your insight
last week it was joe biden this week is
donald trump's turn in the spotlight
republicans have kicked off their
convention solidifying trump as the
party's presidential nominee for a
second time
their four-day convention is aimed at
firing up the base but it may not do
much to win over americans
who are on the fence about giving trump
another term
jackson proskow reports
[Applause]
with his country in crisis and with
americans deeply unsatisfied
president donald trump defiantly
accepted his party's nomination
the only way they can take this election
away from us
is if this is a rigged election touting
baseless conspiracies trump fired off a
familiar list of mistruths and
grievances
because we have to win this is the most
important election
in the history of our country a preview
of the convention
and campaign to come what we're going to
do is make a very clear picture
of how america is a better place today
than it was
before president trump's election
night one features the saint louis
couple who pointed their guns at black
lives matter protesters
trump's son don jr will be the first of
six trump family members to speak this
week
their voices of grievance unlikely to
acknowledge the deep challenges gripping
the u.s
covet is going to play into this and um
i
there's just no way to deny it that's
that's like the elephant in the room
um but ultimately it is going to be
personality and it is going to be
about leadership ability which is why
republicans have decided they don't need
a new platform
not when they've gone all in on trump
the party voted to give blanket support
to the president's agenda
believing that's all it will take to
beat joe biden and the democrats
well we're going to take our case to the
american people it's a case of
lower taxes free market economics
secure borders right to
life it may be a tough sell shortly
before trump was confirmed as his
party's candidate
27 former republican lawmakers announced
their support for joe biden
and tonight trump faces another blow
from within his own administration
his longtime advisor kellyanne conway
has announced she's leaving the white
house to focus on her family conway's
husband is an
outspoken trump critic and the couple's
15 year old daughter has publicly
announced
she's seeking legal emancipation from
her parents
robin jackson prescott washington thanks
jackson
ahead of the convention's kickoff
president trump put pressure on the u.s
food and drug administration to
authorize the use of donated blood
plasma to treat covet 19 patients
trump accused the agency of stalling its
approval but as eric sorensen reports
critics say the program is going forward
before large-scale trials have even been
completed
john keating had covet 19 now he's
donating his blood plasma to help
others who are infected it's one of the
most promising treatments for covet 19
antibodies that can neutralize the virus
u.s president trump
hailed the food and drug administration
and his own speed in authorizing it
a more traditional administration where
they would have taken years to come up
with this stuff
the approval came just a day after trump
suggested the fda was conspiring to hold
up the treatment
tweeting obviously they are hoping to
delay the answer until after november
third
election day the fda commissioner
defends the sudden authorization saying
early tests show a 35 percent
improvement in survival
now we're waiting for more data but this
clearly meets the criteria that we've
established for
emergency use authorization but some
specialists worry whether science is
being bent
to the will of politics there is a lot
of
non-science influence that i'm seeing
whether it's you know press releases
whether it's a political
pressure when you have a new treatment
you want to put it through
rigorous scientific testing before you
are using it on broad groups of people
convalescent plasma has been used for a
hundred years it works like this
patients who've recovered from covet 19
have developed a lot of antibodies
proteins to fight the virus transfusing
their blood plasma can help
current covid victims stave off the
worst effects
but small trials haven't necessarily
identified all
adverse effects or whether immunity will
actually hold
the world health organization says
proper large large-scale tests
aren't finished so results aren't
conclusive the trials have been
relatively small
and at the moment it's still very low
quality
evidence if you've fully recovered from
covet 19
consider donating plasma but the us fda
is now encouraging recovered covet 19
patients to donate
and after his experience john keating is
happy to do so
we all just need to do what we can to
get through this and if this is my
little part to do that i'll do whatever
i can
the big question is fast tracking
antibody treatment at this point
medically justified or politically
reckless eric sorensen global news
toronto researchers in hong kong are
reporting the first documented case of
kova 19
a thirty-three-year-old man was first
diagnosed in late march
four and a half months later researchers
say he contracted a different strain of
the virus
the case raises questions about how long
immunity may last
this is also significant for scientists
who've been working on treatments and
vaccines
based on antibodies confronting a mass
killer in court
you killed your own humanity coming up
families faced the man behind the new
zealand massacre
firefighters in california aren't
getting much of a break from the flames
raging across the state
more lightning was in the forecast
raising fears even more fires might
break out
thankfully that didn't happen crews are
working around the clock to gain some
control over two of the biggest
wildfires in california's history
combined they have burned through nearly
450 000 hectares of land
forcing at least a hundred thousand
people from their homes seven people
have died
a state of emergency has been declared
in kenosha wisconsin where protests
erupted last night
after a police shooting of a black man
the governor has deployed 125 members of
the national guard and a warning
some of the video you're about to see is
disturbing
we stopped the video before it shows
officers firing multiple shots into
jacob lake's back
police were called to a domestic dispute
witnesses say blake was trying to break
up a fight between two women
and that officers attempted to use a
taser on him before following him to his
vehicle
and opening fire the 29 year old is in
hospital in stable condition
his family's lawyer says blake's three
sons were inside the car
when it happened two officers involved
in the shooting are an administrative
leave pending an investigation
and today the city's mayor came face to
face with outraged protesters
because these are under your payroll you
pay them yeah
you are responsible for them you're
responsible for all of their actions
they need to be recommended for
everything that they do yeah so this man
arrested it's on camera there's already
police used tear gas to break up angry
demonstrations overnight
some protesters set vehicles on fire and
smashed store windows
there are chilling new details from last
year's deadly mosque attacks in new
zealand
during the start of his sentencing
hearing a court heard how brenton
tarrant
planned and methodically killed 51
people to lower new zealand's
immigration rates the victims families
and survivors got their first chance to
confront the australian gunman
the 29 year old showed little emotion
while families talked about the horror
they faced
and the torment they still live with
the trauma will live with me forever
the images smell
and sound of the mosque on that they
hunt me
you terrorize the whole new zealand and
said in the whole world
terrence pleaded guilty to 51 counts of
murder
40 counts of attempted murder and one
count of terrorism
it's the first terrorism conviction in
new zealand's history
still ahead the bleak warnings from
health experts as canada's
opioid crisis soars
new research on canada's opioid crisis
has found that most
overdose deaths have been caused by
toxic supply of street drugs
bc alone has seen more than 700 people
die since
january that's compared to just over 200
who have died in that province from
covet 19.
federal officials say the drug problem
cannot be ignored but across the country
there is
little consensus on what needs to be
done in order to save lives
heather yorks west explains joseph
vahamah was just
25 when he took a fatal dose of fentanyl
he purchased on the street
he uh was a loving father of two little
boys
uh so we have the
the trauma for them of losing their
father um
he was a uh well-respected
well-liked colleague new research
published in the canadian medical
association journal
has found that the vast majority of
overdose deaths are caused by a toxic
street drug supply
between 2015 and 2017 fewer than two
percent of opioid deaths were linked to
drugs
that had been properly prescribed the
street illicit drug supply is not safe
right now and is increasingly more
dangerous
as we navigate these changes related to
the cova 19 measures that have been
taken
opioid overdoses have increased
significantly since the beginning of the
pandemic
a lack of safer supply of opioids a
reduction or
change of services and increased
isolation
have all conspired to present an
increased risk of death for people who
use opioids
the combined crises have had hospital
icus in edmonton at near capacity in
recent weeks
but across the country there is
disagreement on how the crisis should
best be handled as bc pushes for
decriminalization and safe supply
alberta's premier has publicly
challenged harm reduction models
federal officials say canada's drug
problem cannot be ignored
we know that you cannot
arrest your way out of an opioid crisis
it is escalating as we speak some of the
gains that were made
prior to covet 19 have unfortunately
been lost
last week the country's health minister
announced a review of supervised
consumption policies
but with so many deaths joseph vahama's
mother worries time
is going to waste and that a safe supply
is needed now
in order to save lives heather urex west
global news
calgary up next the canadian who made
soccer history after taking europe's
top prize
canadian soccer star alfonso davies is
celebrating a dream come
true he helped bayern munich clean up
and become the best team in europe for
sixth time
winning the champions league yesterday
davies who came to canada as a young
refugee
is only 19. and as redmond shannon
reports he's already attained a lifetime
of achievements in soccer arguably only
the world cup is bigger than the uefa
champions league and now
a canadian international has his hands
on the trophy
19 year old alfonso davies only one
other canadian man has won the champions
league
but own hargreaves opted to play for
england
[Applause]
edmonton raised davies has been a
central part of bayern munich's winning
team
the pandemic meant this year's
tournament ended three months late
inside an empty stadium but the noisy
celebrations ran
long into the lisbon night
jesse crowned with an official
recognition of canadian sports stardom
you followed me oh my god yes an
instagram follow from drake
my goal is a play to reach professional
level
davies and his family moved to canada as
liberian refugees when he was five
and it wasn't long before his natural
talent was turning the heads of coaches
he still calls me coach to this day even
though i'm not his coach
he had a glow about him he had um
obviously
performance on the field but you can
tell that there was just
something special something that i
haven't seen before
from a kid that age at just 15 he was
part of the vancouver whitecaps team in
the mls
before becoming the most expensive trade
in major league history
when he was snapped up by german giants
bayern munich
we watched the whole game we had on the
big screen in our meal room and everyone
was in there supporting him and
yeah it was a good experience you bet it
was davey's victory on sunday earned the
white caps an extra 1.5 million dollars
in trade bonuses and this week might get
even better for davies
his canadian girlfriend jordan heidemann
could win the women's champions league
with paris
she plays in her semi-final on wednesday
redmond shannon global news
london how can you not love this story
that is global national for this monday
i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with a surprise at
sea
sean russell was out fishing with his
daughter on sunday when a pair of
humpback whales
put on a show for them now what do you
think
needless to say there was a lot of
excitement thank you for watching
have a great night
i